gentlemen I I appreciate you putting on
a brave face because I you made it
through a whole week of the national
emergency and yeah because of the
invasion coming up from Mexico we have
to do our part on the home front if you
see salsa say something so Donald Trump
is dealing with the emergency spent the
week golfing golfing and poop tweeting
and you know I was afraid this was gonna
happen it's getting a little close to
home for me now because he's now
starting to threaten comedians he was
very upset about starting out live last
week and he said why isn't there
retribution what the [ __ ] does that mean
retribution for comedians and Alec
Baldwin now who plays Trump of course
says he now fears for his family's
safety and they were scared enough
already being Alec Baldwin's family
and of course from some how is the time
dealing with the national emergency to
be tweeting about Jesse Smollett
Smollett I don't know there's pronounce
that but he was Jesse what for Jay was
charged with a felony for filing a false
police report because if there is one
thing Trump cannot abide it is a
self-serving liar and of course of
course
Fox News loves this story of course
because it proves their stupid theory
that racism is a hoax they're saying
five Fox News that the mainstream media
isn't covering the jussie Smollett story
isn't covering up some of them just died
in a stampede but you know Jesse he
wanted to raise his profile so he
allegedly paid two men thirty five
hundred dollars to assault him for being
black and gay something he could have
gotten for free in Texas
and I'm the too many hired allegedly
were we're at least one of them was an
extra on Empire Jesse what were you
thinking never give the extras lines my
right show people know this totally
destroys the previous image I had of
jussie Smollett which was I don't know
who that is
but when I want to come down to our
Jessie you're probably feeling pretty
bad right now don't beat yourself up in
less than 48 hours you've got to host
the Oscars no no host this year Oscars
are Sunday no host because a host might
say something interesting and we can't
have that in America and next year to be
safe no presenters you just grab the
Oscar with your name on it scan it and
bag it yourself that's it was kidding
there was talk this year I'm not getting
about this I'm trying to have as the
host of the Oscars a robot a robot is
that crazy well Ryan Seacrest turned to
dance oh no but I know why you guys are
happy Bernie Sanders is in declared that
he is part of it not quite the way you
were last time I hope you still like him
anyway he's a socialist and a lot of the
party has moved toward him I mean the
big star of the party Alexandria Acacio
Cortez she was a Bernie supporter and is
right on his page people are saying wow
what a dream ticket that would be the 77
year old Jew
and a 29 year old former bartender that
official for socialist that's a dream
ticket in LA that's a third marriage I
love Bernie they asked Bernie about AOC
and he said that's where I get my email
so he and now the boy what a what a day
of scandals r.kelly
today indicted on ten counts of
aggregated sexual abuse prosecutors say
the evidence is so overwhelming he was
named Archbishop of Philadelphia oh so
you know who got caught tonight Robert
Kraft you know who that is he is the the
owner of the New England Patriots
charged with soliciting prostitutes at a
Florida massage parlor a rub-and-tug
millionaire is that a rub-and-tug
in Florida man he won six Super Bowls he
needs more happy endings
you know I I always know the Patriots
were cheaters
but what an excuse Robert crafting he
says he was just deflating his balls
you